guys to the samsung stage it's day two
closing this it's the Twilight hours of
day two I think at a 3 here I'm cam
Robinson I'm your host I'm joined by our
I'm wearing me talking payday 2 the big
bank heist that's right man peytie - all
right so short payday 2 is an action
co-op game got so little time man and we
got a nice to finish right back we got a
Rob alright so payday 2 co-op game for
players right it's basically robbing
banks with your friends
great that's what I do in real life so
yeah there's no plan for their game safe
so it came out last summer right we had
a stage here at e3 as well back then and
we've been continued developing it since
then right and what we've done is that
we released 30 updates via 3030 updates
some some of it free some good paid and
some of it you know hot fixes and saw
that all of that but we got is payday 2
and beta 2 and just got this new update
called the Big Bang DLC right yeah so I
don't know if you've seen it but we
forgot the dentist so the dentist is a
new contact and the dentist gives you
jobs right and the depth is played by
John Cole Esposito known from Breaking
Bad you know the usual suspects and so
on so in this heist the big bank which
is the first out of four different hi
yes yes he's gonna ask you to do the big
bank job he asks you to do the green
casino heist that Hope Diamond and he's
also gonna ask you to rescue old hoxton
from the first game right okay so yeah
so in the big bank heist there are some
things you got to do you got a new
feature called pre-planning so
pre-planning is something you do before
the heist because we're all about you
know making the most advanced high scam
there is you know in pre-planning the
gamers just hole up you know they talk
about what we want to do they got the
blueprints of the heist you know out in
front of them and they can pick and
choose you know what they want to do you
come for example you know ask if you
want to have if you want to have a
helicopter to get you out of the heist
afterwards you can do that if you want
to have a bus go through the wall you
know and crash them and you can do that
you know it's up to the players so what
you can see live right now is that we're
in the big bank right so this Bank has
never been hit before
okay right so we're
the first one to do it's called the
benevolent bank but we just call it the
big bank right because that's exactly
what it is so you're sending up a zip
lines they just said yeah so we got zip
lines it's a new feature from a couple
of weeks back one of the free features
we've added to the game so he just used
the zip line to get up to the crane cuz
you know obviously these guys screwed up
right just for the demo yeah well if you
screw up it's straight to plan B
otherwise you can you know you can case
the joint you can do stealth you know
you don't even have to fire a bullet to
complete a heist but in this case you
know they're like screwing all right
let's go right in guns blazing so what
do they need to do you know it's they
need to bring up this big piggy bank so
you know pay the feeding franchise has
been out for some time right and during
that time no a lot of local police
officers I have been wounded and so on
so the local community put together a
big piggy bank you know as like a you
know to help out the local police right
but their payday gang found some way to
use it anyway right so what they're
doing is that they've filled that the
piggy bank with parts of the drill so
there's the drill in there called the
Beast so you as a player have to put
those parts together in front of our
vault
what they're doing right now is they're
using the crane because it's really
heavy the big right to lift it up and
put it out drop it into the glass glass
ceiling of the walls and when it
explodes the guys gotta pick up the
parts up and they gotta go in and drill
the ball that's why he shot at the glass
so I was wondering I did that when you
zip lining up yeah
but surely I mean the piggle just pull
straight do that anyway right
yeah it's a heavy pig but it's gonna
break you know in these balls but yeah
it's awesome
so what what's new in there and this
feel scene apart from this this
particular location like yeah it's
bigger location and really you know it's
it's a girl's back to the first game
because the first game was all about you
know the bigger heights you know the
crazy stuff happening you know you
throwing people out of rooms and stuff
like that so this heist is super huge
it's got a huge vault you know and and
in a lot of different ways you can
attack it but other than that it's the
pre-planning feature we also got four
new masks based on the original
president you know George Washington for
example yeah and it's not you know like
his real-life replica it's actually no
from the dollar bill yes it looks a
pretty weird you know but it's
it's cool it's one of the features you
know in faded to that we've made better
you know since payday the heist is that
is that the mask system for example in
Katy the heist it was really static you
know you could only choose between a
dose and couple of masks and that's it
right you could have modified them in
any way but in PT 2 there's millions of
variations right we got like 90 plus
masks you got the mask you know and then
you can change the pattern you can
change the color of the mask you can
change the material cool so there's like
millions different combinations right so
that's just one of the things right so
as you can see that it's the the big
bank has a lot of open areas where you
have to find and defense the fans have
been asking for a big bank for a long
time you know like a larger banks
because there's already banks in the
game but the fans think there's too
small and you know we listen we do
whatever they want us to do and now
we're delivering so we're carrying the
Beast right now these are the parts that
are inside the pig right yeah yeah
precisely so yeah so it says in the top
bottom right corner he's carrying the
beats so that's one of the parts yeah
he's assembled to be so what were they
gonna assemble this piece that they were
gonna yeah in front of the vault
so that's where he's heading right now
it just has to take care of the law
enforcers first
oh he's heavy he's really slowed down
yeah he's really slowed down cuz you
gotta carry you know we've got to put it
on your shoulder you gotta walk there
you know under and the pieces Harry so
something you know we're really proud of
when it comes to our games you know is
that since we own our own IP you know
when of course working with a great
partner with 505 games right but since
we own the IP we want to work on it and
make it the best we possibly can right
and we want to make our fans you know
right by giving them there's the cool
coolest stuff they can possibly get so
that's why we've done a lot of free
stuff you know previously just before we
released this one we did a free heist
like a stealth
hice called the shadow raid heist yeah
where you got to get into a big
warehouse during night time and steal a
samurai armor but now yeah so on Tuesday
this is gonna be real here we go the
third part is ready it's great let's see
we're starting it and vari going man the
cool thing is that 82 is just like its
predecessor there's a lot of random
geometry so in this in this heist
specifically we've tried to take that to
a different level so that the vault can
be on different places and when you go
into the vault
the setting is completely different
right one time it's just one floor you
know and some some cash flying about yet
another time it can be two floors inside
the vault with gold all over the place
right so you never know it's he gonna
never know it sometimes you hit it big
sometimes it doesn't and that's just
like you know I wouldn't know but that's
just like you know utilized in areas
like in real life not that I would know
gosh there's always something that goes
wrong to keep your mask on yeah yeah
there's always something that goes wrong
with the high side and we're trying to
replicate movies of tell me anything
yeah it was so what kind of fan
obviously you guys are heavily
influenced by my movies and pop culture
and what what do you for you some of
your like biggest draws if a day
obviously you know we were so inspired
by heat right yeah it's a great movie
you know but there's you know also you
know other games other movies you know
definitely you know
the town and so on you mentioned you
could end it with a you know you could
escape could be a bus through the wall
maybe a school bus yeah yeah yeah well
you know we get it we get our references
from here and there you know but the
fans love that you know and we love to
reference the fans too you know so we
got like a lot of graffiti in the game
with the fans names and so on speaking
offense if you are fed up a day to and
you're watching this right now then if
you've got a question for a merit then
but absolutely send me a tweet to act
cam Franz Rob that's at C a.m. f ra said
ro B and I will be downstage and yeah
well it's straight to the man right now
you can ask us anything you want enough
upcoming updates just haven't happened
yet if you want to do another 30 in the
next six months you know just let it
just tweet at me and I will ask him so
what what what's going on now we've
we've got it to be inside the vault now
yeah do remember trilling they're still
drilling there so chillin yeah yeah so
we're just running out the law
enforcement seems looking at the drill
right now it says 45 seconds yeah
they're almost there in 45 seconds we're
gonna go in banging go to Twitter and
see if anyone's you got to repair the
drill as well oh you know it's funny no
of course we can sheets it in there
damage it the community is always you
know talking like white doesn't the crew
have better drills why do they always
break down you know but it's an
alternate universe right we can't have
everything perfect in the game the
drills have to break to make it
interesting
oh we've got a first question already
okay so Derek's Andy asks will there
well there later be a payday 2 complete
edition with the base game and all of
the DLC so are you planning to do like a
a game of the year type complete edition
some point I think that would be awesome
yeah to like reduce the total of price
and so on yeah that'd be a cool thing
there's nothing we don't we haven't any
we haven't done in like official release
of that yet or whatever but that sounds
like a great idea
there you go another question here from
Andrew Carnegie says how many more masks
are gonna be added into the game he did
mention this anymore mask yeah yeah yeah
how many more oh that we wouldn't know
we usually add four more messed with
each DLC or each free DLC yeah yeah
there's actually two masks you can get
right now during e3 oh yeah yeah yeah so
if you get it through the Humble Bundle
you can get to unique masks just for a
dollar so make sure you go online check
out that III digital ticket if you
aren't here and they get two masses
right away tons of questions actually so
this one from this one from Sam Wood
says will the PC DLC come to xbox 360
just did the release it's great to hear
from the Xbox players as well we just
did a press release yesterday oh yeah
where we said that the first three deal
sees this car coming out soon that's
really happy about because we know you
know they've been hurting for a more
content and PlayStation 3 as well yeah
and there's a separate question from
Paul Larsen so there you go oh yes where
well also well DLC update supplying two
previous missions if they'll do what now
both DLC update supply to like previous
content basically yeah yeah the
pre-planning is for the big bank for now
but we're thinking about implementing
you know you don't need to pre-plan that
much if you're just gonna hit a
convenience store am i right yeah you
wouldn't know but yeah I guess I got my
resources right we got a question here
from mr. Robert says hi guys hi al mere
there you go I will people Pete gold old
hoxton voice being new phil character
after the bank heist double question
work triple yeah beat gold of course
he'll voice old hoxton I mean that's the
whole point right
yeah and fact yeah that's what someone
else asks is how is the new sons old
voice Hoxton complex dad or might I just
that that is assuming that the community
will be able to help him out right
because the dentist you know it played
by John Cole Esposito he said that he
knows how to get old hoxton out of jail
right but it's up for the players to
decide if they're able to do that or not
so it's challenge all right another
question we get loads of questions man
this isn't yeah fans are awesome I mean
I see well speaker
it's a back layer dynamic yeah you kind
of lose that already say there's a boat
I would say it's the big bank is a
throwback to the first game we're trying
to find the core of the payday franchise
so it's a lot more dynamic than other
missions have been in the past and it's
you know it's just us listening to what
the community want and running with it
I've completed the job which is great
well done it's a real quick so nice yeah
during e3 people can come here we're in
the consumer area so anyone without even
without a casino versus another one here
oh it's the female hyster still coming
we gotta know yeah yeah of course she is
we just have to find the right time
stock to the releaser excellent so
that's a feature update will there ever
be a Batman mask Oh some we'd have to
talk with those guys yes okay I mean if
you ask me of course I love the Batman
mask I'd love I'd love all that kind
stuff
I would love a gamespot mask yeah yeah
because I am the man who makes all
decisions again oh yeah here's the
question will there will there ever be a
two-player co-op mode or a set of
missions for less than four people so
have you ever thought of that I said
nothing we have discussed at the moment
I always wanted we aim on four players
bucket is something we've done with it
with the big bank is that right now you
can do up in the big bank we've
introduced a new feature where you can
actually do several objectives
simultaneously previously notice more
line here like do this do that do this
then you know but now you can actually
do several things at the same time this
means that people can split up into two
different groups okay then you know then
you have two people doing two missions
right but like making exclusive missions
for two people I have a hard time seeing
that happen but you know if the fans
want it we can talk about it on the
forums on Steam you guys ever thought
like TV - you know you mean recording
hardline you know we welcome the
competition that's awesome I wish those
guys the best of luck because we think
we're gonna make very high schemes if we
get some good competition but you know
we're focusing more on the highest
experience you know like at the Quentin
Tarantino heist like yeah so so yeah but
some competition PvP you know right now
we don't have any official word on it
we'd like to focus on the court co-op
experience because I mean if you're
looking to eat for example they're not
fighting against out of the Roberts or
whatever I'm there it's four or five
guys no it's a spike crew making a heist
making sure they get out you know and
whatever follows that it's been an
absolute pleasure me and you and Jenny
to the big blackeyes yeah great fun
times and so when when can people get
their hands on the DLC Tuesday we'll be
able to yeah we'll have the creatures
looking into this it did the e3 building
we kept some other cool streamers team
evil some other cool guys are gonna be
able to stream it on Twitch and so on so
that's gonna be awesome yeah well yeah
great to have you on and join the rest
of you three and coming up next guys we
are gonna just go and check out some
retro gaming this is a I'm gonna head
off now have a break maybe a glass of
water
who knows go crazy but I will be back
tomorrow for a much more live stage show
but Chris waters will be replacing me in
this comfortable black chair but I'll
see you guys I'll see you guys tomorrow